Hello, welcome to today's episode.
Today we're gonna show you
how to fix the red ring issue,
my way.
It's actually red ring.
Yes, I'll fix that.
It's not because there's no
video game inside or anything.
No.
Who wrote on this?
It is my brother and
his two mates I think.
What does that say?
I have to blur that out.
I think it's a bit atrocious.
Yeah.
So let's take one each, and.
And this game as well,
it's my favorite game.
Nice.
Flipping egg.
Something pops, something
flew out of that.
Smoking, smoking.
Where is the game?
It's right here, it's all right.
Still in one piece.
The game is still okay.
Thank God.
I'll tell you one thing,
I've never actually played
this, but if it survives,
I think I should play the whole thing.
I bet it's actually really good.
Everyone is crazy about
this like of games.
Yeah, I think the dish tray is broken
but the red ring issue
is definitely fixed.
Result.
Yeah, yeah.
Definitely, yeah.
So, maybe because the red LEDs are gone.
It wasn't smoke that came out of the back,
It was just dust.
That explains a lot.
Don't breath this.
I flatly refuse to push the button.
The handle is so wet,
it's hard to hold on to.
You're awful.
You're shocking,
it's gonna be tomorrow
by the time you hit this.
Uh.
Well, that's two red rings
now sorted with our Xbox's.
This one, you can see, that's
not gonna red ring again.
It's not gonna do anything again.
Uh, sorry about your game.
It's screwed, no.
I'll never get to play that now.
Dan,
I'm sorry Dan.
Look, just give me a minute all right.
I'll let you got no where to storm off to.
Somewhere too messy quick.
I've never seen someone
trying to storm out of a field before.